[موسيقى]
لقبه الصقلي اصبح رمزا لكل طبيب حاذق في
عصره الطبيب العلامه ابو العباس احمد عبد
السلام الصقلي الشريف الحسني
لقبت عائلته بالصقلي نسبه الى سقليه التي
هاجرت منها باتجاه تونس واشتهر منها عدد
من الاطباء ابرزهم ابو العباس
كان من اشهر اطباء تونس وافريقيا في عصره
عاش في كنف السلطان ابي فارس عبد العزيز
المتوكل احد اشهر سلاطين الدوله الحفصيه
الذي انشا المارستان بمدينه تونس لمعالجه
المرضى من الضعفاء والمساكين
استفاد ابو العباس الصقلي من الاجواء
المزدهره في تونس ليدرس الطب في جامع
الزيتونه الذي اعتبر في عصره احد اهم
المراكز الفكريه في العالم
تتلمذ على يديه كثير من الطلاب اهمهم
الامامان ابن عرفه والرصاع
اهتم بالجانب النفسي فضلا عن الجانب
العضوي في الطب ويورد تلميذ له في مخطوط
ضمه المكتبه الوطنيه بتونس ان شيخه الشريف
ابا العباس احمد الصقلي كان حاد المزاج
سريع الغضب الى ان اصبح من احلى من الناس
وذكر الرصاع في كتابه الفهرس انه سمع من
شيخه الامام ابن عرفه ان بلدا لا يسكن
فيها الصقلي لا يطيب بها العيش اعترافا
بمقامه وحفقه للطب
وصارت عباره الطبيب الصقلي تطلق على
الطبيب الحاذق نسبه الى ابي العباس
من ابرز مؤلفاته كتاب الادويه المفرده وهو
الكتاب الرئيسي لاحمد الصقلي يشتمل على
عشرين بابا جمع فيها الامراض من الراس الى
القدم
وكتاب في شرح ارجوزه ابن سينا في الطب
وكتاب حفظ الصحه وسمي ايضا الطب الشريف
الفه لامير عصره المتوكل وقسمه الى قسمين
امراض النفس وامراض الجسد
توفي وفق الراجح في العام 1418
من اشهر اقواله العاده طبيعه مستفاده
والغضوب يروض نفسه حتى يرجع حليما
[موسيقى]